senator-elect john mccain from arizona
it seems everyone has made a comment or
two about President Reagan's comments
last night at his press conference would
you care to add your comments to this
what was your sins well I I think that
the President did a reasonably good job
given the fact that I think that the
administration has made a mistake and I
think most Americans feel that supplying
arms to Iran even with the best of
intentions is not something that they
would support and I hope and believe
really over time that this mistake will
be viewed in the context of what I think
has been overall a very successful
foreign policy over the six years of
this administration so far and the
sooner that the administration can put
this issue behind us assure the American
people one that it's not going to happen
again and two that the appropriate
committees in Congress at least are
notified in ain't quote timely fashion I
think the better off we'll be and yet at
the same time let's not forget that the
goal of the president and all of us is
to get those Americans back we're being
held hostage and I'm sure that was the
motivating force and might have led to
errors in judgment which otherwise
wouldn't been made okay as you know
julen I am a strong supporter of this
president and I believe in him and I I
haven't always agreed with him but at
the same time this time they have made a
mistake and the sooner they can get it
all ventilated and behind us I think the
better off the country will be as well
as the president well thank you sir
again we are with senator elect John
McCain who is a Republican from Arizona
he's also currently sitting as a
congressman from Arizona and we'd like
for you to call us or ask him questions
we're going to be talking about
President Reagan and Iran and about the
fact that the senator elect is going to
be going across the aisle and another
aisle exactly what street
yes across the street to change his his
changes title the numbers to call or if
you are in the eastern or central time
zones area code 202 six to eight to five
to five if you are in the Pacific or
mountain time zones area code 202 seven
three to seven to seven those of you who
are constituents of a senator elect
McCain I guess they would be in the
Pacific mountain what parts of the state
of any type yes Mountain time we in
Arizona
julen or one of the only places in
America that we don't go on or off
daylight savings time we we stay
it's a states right issue and also we
have lots of sunshine in Arizona so we
don't change so half the year we are on
California time where Pacific Coast time
and half the year we are well that's
interesting other time okay I'd like to
talk for a few minutes about President
Reagan's farewell dinner tonight you
attended that earlier this evening and
as I understand it he said that people
should the GOP should stick together in
the Democratic controlled house and the
Senate yes it wasn't a happy occasion
tonight as you know being one of 250
percent of the new Republican senators
is not the most joyous thing and we did
say goodbye tonight to some of the
senators who were defeated as you know
there were eight of the incoming class
of 1988 of the 16 were defeated and
there was a bit of nostalgia and sadness
of course but the president was upbeat
and talked about party unity and the
fact that we can still be extremely
effective and work on the agenda that
the people gave him both in 1980 in the
1984 we don't want to forget he was
reelected by 49 of the 50 states and it
was so there was a lot of mixed emotions
and not a pleasant evening as far as
having to say goodbye to some people
that worked very hard for their state
and for this country but it's that's the
game yeah it's the process and I think
most of us appreciate that he didn't
mention Iran at all did he no no he
didn't talk about that it was more of a
kind of a farewell type of a thing
rather than well today on Capitol Hill
there was certainly a number of comments
made about the president's recumbents at
his press conference last night I just
like to read you something that the
House Democratic Leader Jim Wright said
today he said that the law requiring
timely notification of covert operations
did not permit the
resident to wait ten months before
informing Congress of his actions the
law has really not been followed are
they nitpicking or is this an important
issue that that could cause problems
later on well I have to say that I agree
with majority leader right that it is
not timely I don't think a 10 month
lapse of time is timely and I also have
to question as to what's going on with
national security council I think that
if we're going to have credibility with
the American people we've got to comply
in a timely fashion at the same time
let's be fully aware that almost every
time that enough people at work on the
hill are notified of something it's not
very long before it's leaked to the
press and so I think there's a careful
balancing act as to how much you should
and can if you want to preserve secrecy
you remember not too long ago there was
leaked to the press a story about how we
were attempting to or there was a plan
for a destabilization of Qaddafi I'm not
talking about the misinformation when
I'm talking about the destabilization
one and I'm not sure who that helped
besides Qaddafi and so I think that
there's a very careful balance here and
in this and I understand their desire to
keep it secret but at the same time it's
not only that Congress wasn't informed
about this but from the media and that's
all I know it appears as if George
Shultz and cap Weinberger the true yes
we're not informed of this I happen to
admire George Shultz in capillary and I
have great faith in our Joint Chiefs of
Staff the people that are selected to
lead our military and I have to ask the
question as the American people will
would this operation as proceeded as far
as it did if those people's opinions had
been solicited and they had been
informed the other one that surprises a
lot of us of course is Budd McFarland's
role in this and I've also been a great
admirer of Budd McFarland's I think his
reputation when he was the national
security adviser was excellent as you
know they handled a number of operations
and a number of
from small to incidents such as the
bombing raid in Libya or the Grenada
operation two very long-term policies
which I think were valuable to the
United States and to our security so
it's it's a little hard to fathom some
of this explain that process to me
because it would seem that if you tell
Congress something that's obviously top
secret and perhaps should be kept secret
then as you say it will get out is there
a is there a process or something that
there only certain members of Congress
would know something or and with the
promise that they wouldn't tell anybody
how does that work well julen we have to
go back to the church
investigation the church hearings of the
CIA of the abuses of CIA in the middle
70s and as a result of the revelations
of abuses by the CIA the various pieces
of legislation were passed and the
legislature the intelligence committees
were formed up to that time there was
like only two people in all of Congress
that were told of covert activities then
the intelligence committees were formed
and part of this legislation about a
timely fashion came about now again I
have to sympathize anyway with those
people who were trying to keep it secret
for example I don't know if you remember
or not but when the certain members of
Congress were briefed that the raid was
on its way to Libya the f-111s were on
their way one of the members of Congress
basically told the media that it was
about to happen fortunately it appears
that mr. Gaddafi was not watching TV
that night or didn't have the wire but
you know that could have been very
dangerous and could have caused the
death or loss of US pilots and equipment
so I don't think there's any doubt that
the hill quote leaks like a sieve but I
also think that most members of the
Intelligence Committee and staffers do
abide by the secrecy and they hold that
confidentiality but having seven four
years in the house I know those people
had served on the Intelligence Committee
and they did keep things secret to a
great degree
unfortunately there's also many things
that have leaked out and which have not
been helpful to the United States
they shall spell or even evil you tell
them or indeed portunity it has four
afford to get out indeed I'm going to
switch subjects with you for a minute
and we're gonna talk about you're moving
across the street you've been in
Congress how long four years and now
you're moving over to the Senate how is
that going to change how you were react
to your constituent needs well I would
hope that I would be as reactive and as
sensitive to the needs of my
constituents I think that one of the
reasons one of the major reasons why I
was successful in the Senate campaign is
because I went back to my home state
Arizona almost every weekend and and we
had a good staff and good constituent
service I think that's a one of the
reasons why I was elected and I think
that if I want to remain in the United
States Senate and I'm certainly not
looking forward to another campaign
right right but if I want to remain
there I've got to be sensitive have good
constituent work and work for the
interests of my state that doesn't mean
to the exclusion of national interests
certainly Barry Goldwater who was my
predecessor contributed enormous Lea to
this country in a variety of ways
primarily in defense armed services but
he also contributed great deal
philosophically as we all know because
he he was responsible for a shift in in
the certainly the towards conservativism
with the whole country indeed but I
think it's important for a senator or
two to be responsive and I think that I
will be back as often as possible I have
two small children and I would like for
them to grow up in Arizona which is a
beautiful place to live we have our
first caller as a matter of fact from
Phoenix Arizona go ahead please
[Applause]
I'm very proud of them what would you
like to see him do ma'am well continue
to support the person in any way thank
you very much for thank you that was
that was not a paid political actually
no but I appreciate that in I appreciate
the caller and but you don't always
support President Reagan you broken away
from know there's been there's been
occasions where I have not supported the
president it hasn't been pleasant for me
to do that and it's always after a lot
of thought and a lot of contemplation
and talked with conversations with
others before I've done that I did not
support sending the Marines into Lebanon
and I felt that was a serious mistake
I wish I had been wrong because 273
young Americans would be alive today but
there was a few other occasions but I
have consistently supported what the
president is trying to do for America
and I think he has put America on the
right path and I think he's caused a
degree of optimism and hope amongst
Americans young and old and trust and
confidence which we hadn't seen in a
number of years at the same time I think
he's human and has made some mistakes as
the Iranian thing I think was an example
of Austin Texas go ahead please with
your question outrageous statement and
before I hang up I just want to say that
I think we're President Reagan business
right I think he said on to Iran because
it's a strategic importance and not
because of the hostages and it is my
opinion that the Democrats are for the
sole purpose thank you sir thank you sir
first of all I reject the allegation by
mr. O'Neill that the president was
trying to affect the elections
by obtaining the release of the hostages
I give the president a great deal more
credit he was trying to get the hostages
released because he wanted Americans
freed from bondage and I would I think
it's unconscionable to ascribe other
motivations to him now as far as the
president doing the right thing
I also agree that Iran is very important
strategically and I also remember under
whose administration that Ayatollah came
to power and Americans were held hostage
for a long period of time but at the
same time I do not believe and I do not
agree with the president that sending
arms to Iran at this time is in any way
beneficial to the United States interest
in the Middle East or in Iran because I
do not believe that you can deal with
those fanatics I think that if the
Ayatollah passes on to his reward and
others more moderate take his place then
perhaps they can be dealt with but I
just think we have proven by the
reaction of the Iranians and the way
they've been treating this issue that it
was not a useful exercise I would also
like to point out that if Iran wins that
war that can cause an enormous impact
throughout the Middle East our so-called
friends the moderate Arab states will be
scared to death and they will be much
more reluctant to side with us in any
areas including the Middle East peace
process because they will be scared to
death because their threats of Iranian
export ups of this fundamentalist terror
ISM into their country and I would
suggest that perhaps the best thing that
could happen would be a continued
stalemate or between Iraq and Iran as
opposed to having the Iranians prevail
and the Iranians already have
substantial advantages in manpower and
certainly fanaticism and now if we're
going to provide them with a thousand
tow missiles has appeared in the
newspapers I think it would help them a
great deal so the caller and I are in
some disagreement on it okay Reno Nevada
go ahead please with your question I was
wondering what did you think Senator
McCain is it McCain McCain whether or
not you felt that the
press seem to not be able to get the
people to go against their president
therefore they are going to what they
typically when the identity
democratically it seems the president is
turning more towards the Democrats and
whenever a Republican is in they go for
the personal attacks to the president
therefore undermining him as an example
of attempting to call him a liar last
night then I have a couple of comments
as to what I interpreted to be the
situation and maybe you could please
clarify it my understanding was that was
under President Carter the Iranians
became hostile extremely hostile to us
and called us satanic due to the fact
that we had cut off I believe 12 billion
dollars of their money the opening to
the Middle East according to President
Reagan was to give back some of their
money and to complete President Carter's
contract the Democratic Party's contract
of selling arms to Iran and that was
what President Reagan was trying to do
and very quickly on SIDS in the Congress
could you please clarify in the West
we've been told that congressman Dellums
when we were going to rescue Grenada
when the president was murdered by the
communist takeover that congressman
Dellums
got on the shortwave to Grenada telling
the people who took over the government
that we were coming could you clarify
this dirt yes thank you I have heard no
evidence whatsoever that congressman
Dellums
was involved in the Grenada operation
and I think I would have heard if if
that were indeed the case as far as the
history of our relations with Iran is
concerned my version of what happened
was that
the Carter Administration presided when
the Ayatollah was brought back from
France to Iran and the Shah was
overthrown there was a great deal of
protests about the Shah about how
autocratic he was in soo bahk and all
the problems that that goes with a
fellow who was emperor of emperors or
whatever he called himself in retrospect
obviously we ended up far worse off with
the Shah being replaced by the Ayatollah
the hostages were then taken part of the
agreement when the hostages were
returned was that certain amounts of
money that were owed to the Iranian
government would be adjudicated through
the World Court and monies that were
owed the u.s. etc and there was money
and I believe there still is monies that
are owed the Iranians that were locked
up when the hostages were taken by the
Iranians there was no contract that I
know of that was made between the Carter
Administration and remember they were
released I think on the last day or the
day of inauguration there was no
contract that I know of to sell arms or
give arms to the Iranian government as
far as the press is concerned yes I
think that the press came off badly in
the press conference last night because
they became so aggressive with the
president and at one point even
corrected the president about what a
missile is used for and gave the wrong
correction by the way and I don't think
that the press conducted themselves at
least the White House press corps in
that press conference last night at the
same time I think that the President had
to correct make a correction in a rather
serious error I think as far as the role
of Israel is concerned in this whole
operation so in my opinion I don't think
the president came off nearly as well as
he usually does and I don't think the
press came off very well either
I'd like to mention a poll that was
taken to a rather yesterday after
president's news conference and it says
that this is from UPI and the poll was
taken by ABC News it showed that more
than half of Americans surveyed think
President Reagan is lying about the
secret u.s. arms deal with Iran and
three-fourths disapprove of the
trations action however it also says
that 57% still think President Reagan is
doing a good job and 62% are confident
he will make the right decisions about
the world affairs that's according to a
poll taken by ABC News and I think
that's very important Yulin because I
think that the American people as
opposed to the Washington press corps
view this situation in the context of
six years of really admirable service as
present in the United States and even
though they disagree with him on this
particular issue they he has built up a
reservoir of goodwill the Syria excuse
me the Libyan bombing raid the hijacking
of the skyjackers so many other
activities of Grenada rescue operation
and others that I think the president
will probably maintain that popularity
even if the president though if the
people disapprove of this probably what
may be viewed by historians as a low
point in his administration is at least
as far as foreign policy is concerned
okay let's go to our next call Mount
Hope Alabama go ahead please thank you
for seeing me enjoy to question the
president has been chopped with his
party the Democrat Party in the news
maybe now we've got American hostages
that we don't know how they're being
treated or anything of this nature and
whatever the president does the news
meters senators and congressmen chop his
head off
would you support the military operation
to go in there and liberate those people
yes sir
first of all I agree totally and I think
the American people do absolutely
totally that the goal of freeing
American hostages is a laudable one in
one which we should make the most
strenuous efforts to achieve that goal
let me also point out that unfortunately
even though three Americans have been
released three more Americans have been
taken hostage and it appears to many of
us that every time they release one it
wouldn't be very difficult to go out and
grab another which would put us on a
treadmill which is certainly not
productive in
past history indicates that if you
encourage terrorists by paying them off
then it encourages them to further acts
of terror and I and I for one hope that
what I'm saying here tonight is not
chopping the president's head off
because I have said that I agree it with
and support the president at the same
time I think that this particular
operation was a mistake and I think the
Secretary of State does too by the way
what I would support a military rescue
operation if that rescue operation had a
reasonable and I'm talking a 80 to 90
percent chance of success but I wouldn't
suggest a disaster such has happened in
the end of the Carter Administration the
desert one where we not only lost lives
but we also caused the deaths of people
who are supporting us with in Tehran who
were helping us out there so yes I would
support a military effort to rescue
those hostages but I think that would
have to be given a pretty good chance of
succeeding because the risks that are
associated with failure of course are
the consequences are very severe okay I
believe it's to woloson Oregon thank you
yes oh by the way as far as this thing's
great good I figure the guy played a
long shot out of petty cash that's what
we hired the poor when you put somebody
in command you gotta let them obviously
there's a balance but a lot of the
things just straight back but as far as
I could tell I think that just how
things up in in general well in any case
but ultimately my question is you were
Republican in the House of
Representatives I wanted if you feel you
could I'd like your frank evaluation
what's going on in terms of the House
Democratic leadership particularly as it
refers to what I guess they call the
class of 1974 the one the ones who have
stayed in I guess it's kind of
subcommittee management
well I sometimes wonder where some of
these what kind of planet eat some of
these people have been living on what
particular when it comes to formulation
I was just finding now that you're out
you think you could tell us a little bit
about that place and what it is they
think they're doing over there
well first of all I think we have to
accept the fact that that these people
are the result of the electoral process
which despite its flaws is still the
best one that I know of that we can come
up with yes indeed there are the
so-called Watergate babies of the 1974
group which are now assuming positions
of immensely increased power and
authority and many of them in my opinion
are much more liberal than the
mainstream of American thinking let's
not forget however their constituents
continue to return them to office so
that's something we can't forget but
I've said this before when I was in the
House of Representatives and it's true
what has happened in the House of
Representatives which disturbs me is
that there is such a strong liberal
element that it appears to me that if
you want to achieve positions of
authority and power in the House of
Representatives you have to be more
liberal than perhaps you otherwise would
be there's certain liberal line that has
to be hewed and I just would give an
example of that and that is that
Chairman les Aspin of the House Armed
Services Committee as we know voted in
favor of aid to the Contras and
immediately there was an ear up rising
in the Democratic caucus where there is
now still conversation that he will be
challenged for his chairmanship of the
House Armed Services Committee because
of that vote and I think one other that
they didn't like so I don't think
there's any doubt at least in my opinion
that there is a element that controls
basically policy in the House of
Representatives which in my opinion and
it's certainly just my opinion is more
liberal than that of mainstream America
Augusta Georgia go ahead please hello
hello King congratulations on your
election to the Senate thank you
I'm from Augusta Georgia as you might
know and in the 84 elections are
supported the president and also senator
Mattingly hi Ella I didn't support some
of the Mattingly this time I've always
voted a split ticket and for the
individual I've noticed some comments
that you've made the night and you've
seen more of what I call a moderate
conservative rather than a an extreme
rightist on on many things and I think
that's the kind of senators that we need
to represent us from each and every
state in the Union one thing you did say
that you would support going in to
Lebanon to bring out the hostages that
we have there now a number of my friends
and I were talking at these people were
in an area
that you were dangerous to be in there
making more money there than they would
here in America they're paying less
taxes there than they would hear in
America they are there for personal gain
they might have some kind of out of
allottee that they're interested in
carrying on but basically they're
they're just like you and I working for
a job we're gonna get something back for
what we put into this I wouldn't risk
the life I'm a disabled veteran myself I
wouldn't risk the life of one American
to go into Lebanon to bring out someone
that mute they were in danger on their
own
another thing last evening and I'm sorry
to say this President Reagan in many
respects reminded me of my father I used
to play checkers with him when he was
about President Reagan late I didn't
notice it but my father's mind begins to
slow down in the manner in which he
moved his checkers
he went from a championship player to
below average and the way the president
has channeled his news conferences his
speeches
his campaigning the remarks that he made
I just wonder if he still has the
competency to be the leader of our
nation
sir I'm I'm going to have to let the
senator answer some of the things that
you've talked about thank you for
calling first of all sir
thank you since you've mentioned you're
a disabled veteran I'd like to thank you
for your service to our country and I
mean that sincerely
I have seen the president a short time
ago as this evening and I can assure you
from a very close-up viewpoint he is
extremely sharp he's extremely has a
great grasp and I think that what we may
have seen on television in that press
conference is the difficulties that he
faced in my opinion in handling a very
difficult situation there's many of us
that feel that perhaps he should have
just said look we made a mistake and
we're not going to do it again but he
didn't choose to take that path and I
can assure you from the things that I
have seen about the president which are
not real frequent but as I say short
time ago this evening he is in excellent
shape
and he still is a great inspiration to
millions of Americans as not only a man
who has served well as president but
also at his age like senator pepper they
are representative pepper in the House
of Representatives that men can reach
well into their 80s as Claude pepper has
and still be as dynamic and and
effective as they were many many years
before and I think that's true of this
president let me just point out about
the military operation I fully
understand your point that those
Americans should not be in Lebanon
should not be working in that area and
they have been warned by our State
Department that their lives are indeed
in danger first of all some of those
people have been hostage for a long time
and that situation was not nearly as
well known to be as dangerous as it is
now but more importantly than that this
nation is founded on the judeo-christian
ethic and that judeo-christian ethic is
that we do try to help others I can
remember during the Vietnam War when one
pilot would be shot down and we would
send 50 airplanes risking the lives of
many others just to try and save one
pilot and in certain occasions we lost
many pilots just in the attempt
sometimes unsuccessful attempt to save
one pilot when I said a military
operation when I meant that would have
to have a good chance of success that
chance of success would also have to be
a factor in that we would not lose
American lives in the effort to make the
rescue of American hostages and also I
appreciate your splitting your ticket I
think it's a healthy situation that
people vote for individuals rather than
parties the only thing I regret about
this election and I hope all of our
viewers share that view is that we had
such a terribly low voter turnout and it
was I was sitting next to senator
d'amato at dinner tonight he told me
they had the lowest voter turnout in New
York State in this last election since
1942 you know a 38% national turnout I
remember the numbers very poor and part
of that was because of negative
campaigning which maybe some of our
viewers would like to comment about too
but thank you for your call in your
comments sir Marysville Washington go
ahead please with your question thank
you miss Lillian congratulations see you
senator on your election the things that
I would like to discuss just briefly
miss Lilly you you made a remark oon in
regards to the UPI and the eight ABC
poll yes and what I'm saying that poll
is speaking with the forked tongue I won
again the poll says hey the president's
doing a great job overall but the minute
that he has a problem while they jump in
and say the people aren't with them and
I live here in the state of Washington
we lost the Senators hip I being a
Republican senator Gordon was defeated
but the thing that I'm trying to bring
out is that whenever there's a slight
miss fewer for a list who that may be
beyond slight the press jumps in there
like vultures and in a good example is
bill Plante he comes out with claws and
daggers and just scratches at the
president now if he has personal
problems with the president and don't
like him I think that he should keep
them between the president himself and
not come out in the public and destroy
what we look upon as the greatest office
in the world the president of
see and I would like to have senator
your comments on the press and how you
feel without putting yourself out on a
limb as to how they handle themselves
thank you and I'll listen to it on TV
well thank you sir first of all I share
your your view about that poll and that
is that I still think that the American
people although disagreeing with this
particular action still have great
strong support and belief in this
president and I think the polls will
continue to show that although I think
the American people are correct in not
approving of this particular part of is
this activity and I think we need to
perhaps take steps to remedy that I
think we should find out how this all
came about so it shouldn't be shouldn't
be repeated but at the same time the
president United States is elected to
conduct foreign policy with the advice
and consent of the Senate as far as the
behavior of the press is concerned I
have to go back to write some time
around Watergate when mr. Wrather when
in a exchange with President Nixon in
50s and the president said what office
are you running for and rather said what
office are you running for mr. president
and that catapulted mr. Wrather to a
certain notoriety throughout the country
and of course he is now obviously been
very successful
senator Eagleton who recently retired
said one time he said every reporter in
this town looks at me like I appeal at
surprise and I think there's some
accuracy to that statement I also think
that anybody who stays in this town too
long without getting out amongst
Americans as a tendency to get a bit
jaded and a bit cynical at the same time
also one other aspect of the press and
their relations with the president they
have been frustrated from time to time
because they don't see to some degree I
think what the American people see in
this president and and I think it
frustrates them that you know the Teflon
president aspect of it and this may be
to some degree what they view is one of
the first real openings they've had and
I believe as I said earlier they
terribly overplayed their hand
last night and I think many Americans
somewhat sympathize with the president
because what seemed to be very
repetitious on the part not just a bill
plant but but on the other members of
the press at the same time I believe
that the majority of the members of
press particularly in my own home state
are honest dedicated people who are
trying to do their duty as they see best
to the American people and they are
prone to errors and mistakes just like
politicians are isn't it possible though
that President Reagan has gone through
his presidency virtually unscathed and
this now is as you were saying that says
this is a chance for the press to take
potshots but it's also the first time in
his presidency that there has been a
major problem that he's had to deal with
I think so I think it's also the first
time of course there have been other
periods you know in 82 when the economy
was in bad shape and those periods but
at the same time I think this is the
first serious foreign policy issue
I came close on the Dan'l off affair but
that was quickly resolved and overtaken
by recchia Vick and and recchia Vick was
was perceived by the American people and
I think accurately is a not as the press
made of portrayed it but as a president
portrayed it as a they say that he stood
up to Gorbachev but this is indeed the
first serious problem and the question
is is how quickly they can put it behind
us and that's not clear yet Emporia
Kansas go ahead please yes I have a
question for Senator McCain first of all
like to congrats on congratulate you on
your winning Republican seat I think you
have a very large bunch of shoes to fill
there because mr. Goldwater is a
tremendous individual and I think he
would have been a present general may
had been so very outspoken on his
nuclear armament but I have a few
questions asked you along the lines that
we're talking this evening I just
finished watching senator Byrd say that
you know he was going to be the next
Senate Majority Leader and I wonder if
it wouldn't be right for the president
to say that okay guy you think you know
so much more than our present Secretary
of State does let's let you be the
Secretary of State I don't know it's
kind of a long shot I wouldn't ever
haven't probably but what would your
thoughts be if it if it could happen and
along the same lines what do you think
was the president action during this
Iranian thing do you think it was legal
if it wasn't what should be done
and along those same lines again under
President Marcos regime and the
Philippines I'm sure we said aramis to
them and I was probably the most corrupt
government that we were friendly with at
the time surely our intelligence
agencies weren't flying you know they
knew it was going on now why are we just
thinking wishing so much between what
was going on under marcos and the
philippines and what was going on in
Iran under the third president
administration and the last question I
would like to ask you is what
legislation you plan to introduce in the
Senate thank you sir
thank you very much sir for your
comments and I appreciate particularly
your comments about Barry Goldwater just
a legend as we all know in the and the
way that he has been treated by his
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
indicates the respect that he's gained
because he has been honest
he has been candid and he has had
integrity even those that have always
disagreed with him admit that first of
all what should be done what was it the
action legal or illegal I would think
that the illegality probably would lie
in this question about whether Congress
was notified in a quote timely fashion
or not technically it would be very
difficult to prove the
was not a timely fashion but I think
realistically that 10 months is too long
and it's not a timely fashion what
should be done I think that we should
evaluate where the role of the NSC is in
this and whether those individuals in
the National Security Council who were
orchestrating this operation should keep
their jobs to be to be blunt and
shouldn't there be activated the kinds
of councils and meetings that would
include secretary Weinberger and
secretary Shultz who are not only our
appointed secretaries but have been
approved by the Senate and whereas the
NSC people are not and we probably need
to consider whether some legislation to
ensure that congressional committees
intelligence committees are notified in
a quote timely fashion that may have to
be tightened although I hate to tie the
hands of the President and conduct of
foreign policy the difference between
the Marcos regime in the Iranian
situation I think is very profound mr.
Marcos was not exporting subversion and
terror into other countries and was not
responsible for the deaths of innocent
Americans they the Marco's never took a
group of Americans hostage and held them
for a year and so that I think there's a
dramatic difference yes mr. Marcos was
corrupt and I'd like to remind you that
we helped overthrow the Marcos regime
and install mrs. Aquino through our
morale and even financial support at the
time that it became clear that mr.
Marcos did not have the support of the
Philippine people and by the way we're
not out of the woods on that one by a
long shot she may face is facing severe
difficulties and there is a possibility
not a probability right now but
possibility that she may be overthrown
but and not to mention the serious
communist insurgency we have the
legislation that I would like to be
involved in remembering that a freshman
senator is not going to now in the
minority party is not going to make a
great impact I'd like to be involved
with the issues that affect my state
first of all and I'd like to be continue
the work of very such as land and water
our central Arizona Project
and our Indian issues Indians owned 27
percent of our state but I'd also like
to continue the work that barry
goldwater established as far as the
reorganization the pentagon and
legislation which would ensure that the
american people get the most efficiency
out of their defense dollars there's a
great cynicism and understandable
reluctance and part of the american
people to spend more money on defense
nowadays when they hear about the $300
hammer and a $600 toilet seat which
gives new meaning to the word throne and
all of the other abuses because if we
want to defend this nation capably then
we've got to convince the American
people that their tax dollars are being
spent wisely and that ranges from
putting people in jail that do those
things to finding out really where our
national security requirements are
including how much of a burden are we
sharing with our European allies and
with our Japanese friends who are
responsible for this enormous trade
deficit of ours
I would suggest one of the great debates
that I would be involved in in the next
year or two or three or four will be
when and where are the Japanese and
particularly going to pick up their
share of defense because we're not going
to defend them forever particularly when
we're looking at these massive trade
deficits that's basically what I'd like
to be involved in and I'm sorry for the
long answer good questions along those
lines are you disappointed that you have
finally gotten into the Senate and it's
no longer a Republican majority and that
you you are a freshman member I mean
those two things are those strikes
against you or are they good for you or
well of course it's very disappointing
of course to come back in the minority
since we're was in the minority of the
House of Representatives but I think
it's very clear that in fact we were
just talking about Senator Barry
Goldwater senator Barry Goldwater was in
the minority almost all of his time in
the United States Senate yet he had
enormous effect you can't have effect in
the Senate if you work hard working in
bipartisan fashion and gain and respect
to your colleagues my first job is to
try through thoughtful hard work and not
being a show horse to earn the respect
of my colleagues and then over time I
think you can have effect okay Las
Cruces New Mexico go ahead please
yes first of all I would like to make
the comment that I think all of this
prolonged discussion about the president
in the Iranian situation with the arms
is getting to the point of being very
depressing as we all know hindsight is
20/20
as mr. McCain had mentioned in the
Grenada incident and other times that
congressional people and Representatives
have not kept to the point of secrecy
which is very important to Americans and
the President and everybody in America
number one mr. McCain I have a question
doesn't it seem that the president was
acting in total sincerity for the
interest of his country number two
witnessing now more than ever would be a
time to rally around the president and
support him for his efforts whatever
hindsight tells us after the fact and
number three if you agree that it would
be a good time to rally around the
president would you tomorrow or tonight
take the time to speak to other
congressmen and representatives and see
if you can't get that message across I
think America needs to get back on an
upbeat situation and off of this cloudy
subject I think that you're exactly
right
first of all yes there was not only some
representatives that disagreed over an
incident like Grenada brought to mind
that we had a couple of congressmen that
wanted to impeach the president you
might remember over the Grenada rescue
operations so he's proving we certainly
have a broad spectrum in the Congress I
do think we ought to put the issue
behind us at the same time I think we've
got to ensure that there's not a
repetition of it not just for the sake
of the American people but also for the
sake of the president so that there's
not a repeat I think that the caller
agrees with me that it was a mistake and
I think that what's going to happen is
that the American people will be get
tired of this beating and continuous let
me say drumbeat on this issue and we'll
want to put
behind us as well and I certainly want
to support this president but let me
also point out that I would think as a
not as a Republican but as an American I
would rally around any president because
he is our president and elected by the
people and I think it's time we put this
behind us and I have already voiced that
opinion to my colleagues and and
surprisingly or not surprisingly a lot
of my colleagues feel the same way that
it's time to put the issue behind us but
at the same time we must I think do what
we can in the President must do what he
can to avoid a repetition of this go
ahead with your question
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
effect events within Iran and if if the
government didn't want because the
Ayatollah does pencil and that
government is a grant we need to
try to use every tool that we've got to
see that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you sir
thank you very much sir and I'd like to
reiterate what the other caller said I
think this one was making the same point
the president is absolutely sincere and
I understand his understand totally
understandable desire to bring about the
release of these Americans that are
being held prisoner and perhaps that
strong desire and the very warm humane
added attitude of the president would
override wrote in my opinion it might be
otherwise good judgment yes Iran is a
serious situation yes the Soviet Union
has been trying to fish in those
troubled waters but let me also remind
the caller that if Iran wins that war
between Iran and Iraq which they may do
and if we help them sufficiently with
arms then after they've consolidated
their position then they pose a great
threat to those oil supplies in the
Middle East and to the so-called
moderate Arab countries such as Saudi
Arabia Jordan and others who are who
live in fear of the Iranian
fundamentalists as it is Hollywood
California go ahead please with your
question yes I have a question that at
the president's news conference there
was a reporter that asked about the tow
missile and there was some question as
as to whether it was a shoulder-fired
weapon as ex-military far as I
understand that tow missile has wires
running to it so in fact the proximity
to a tank which you would have been a
fairly close range with his means would
be a frontline weapon and that it would
be a defensive weapon now a
shoulder-fired missile
could be used almost at anything but
that was one question that I had if the
representative can answer that question
what is it tow missile and the thing is
I don't think mr. Reagan really has to
be concerned about what type of missile
it was as long as his military advisors
explain to him that it was a defensive
missile and in what situation it might
be used go ahead thank you I agree with
the caller's point is I don't think that
the president has to know the mechanics
of every weapon in the United States
inventory and I do believe that it was
nitpicking on the part of the reporter
and then the reporter was hoisted by his
own petard because he said it was an
anti-aircraft missile and indeed it is
not it is a tripod-mounted missile that
goes against tanks and does not in any
way affect airplanes and you're right it
is what we call wire-guided and
relatively short distance it can be
called a defensive missile I guess
because it is for incoming tanks it is
also an extremely formidable weapon and
one which has gone a long way towards
countering tank warfare in particularly
desert regions such as the Iranian wreck
situation Des Moines I will go ahead
please hello President Reagan advocates
developing the Strategic Defense
Initiative and then sharing it with the
Soviets but wouldn't it be a better idea
to jointly develop the SDI with the
Soviets so they don't think we are
gaining the upper hand and then strike
while they still think that they can I
think it would be a good idea if we
could trust the Soviets I think that
when the president says that he would
share our technology once it's developed
I think that he would do that in order
to assure the Soviet Union that we would
not use SDI in order to shield against
theirs and against their missiles and at
the same time launch ours
I believe also that the Soviet Union is
incapable at least in the area of high
technology which we're talking about if
staying up with us so I would not
support sharing that technology with the
Soviet Union for fear they might take
that technology and expend a lot more
money than we have and possibly even get
ahead the Soviets are very good at
copying and then developing they are not
very good at pure technology long beach
california go ahead please my
observation doesn't necessarily have to
do with the merits or the demerits of
the incident itself but i would like to
ask your opinion as a public speaker
about the merits of adopting a
diplomatic rhetoric that makes allowance
for possible future exceptions to a
certain policy as opposed to taking a
rigid consistent line of rhetoric which
then with is unavoidable in creating a
shock among the population of the world
when the action is so drastically
different from the rhetoric and so it
it's not necessarily a political
observation i'm asking but in terms of
he's adopting diplomatic language is
opposed to inflammatory language thank
you very much thank you and i think this
is the one of the major parts of the
problem here with the Iranian situation
and that is that we as a country as a
leader of the free world have
consistently as you mentioned enunciated
and articulated a policy which blocked
any arms sales to the Iranians for
obvious reasons then when it becomes
known that we either allowed or assisted
depending on on whose version you
believe arms to go to Iran then it takes
our allies and friends by surprise and
catches them flat-footed and it also
encourages sends a signal to the arms
dealers throughout the world which there
are many that really they've got a green
light and they can go ahead and sell
arms to the Iranians which they would at
enormous profit so one of the things
about diplomacy is at least in my
opinion the key elements of diplomacy is
a certain concern
in your policy and if you're going to
change that policy you'd better let your
friends and allies know even if it's
quietly and behind-the-scenes otherwise
you make them look foolish and embarrass
them and then the next time a policy is
enunciated by your government
it may not be believed because of
previous violations of stated policy and
that's where we're going to have a
problem in repairing some of the
standards that exists between now and
our credibility with our allies
Millerton Oklahoma please make your
questions short we've only got a few
minutes okay go ahead yes sir this
program otherwise you don't get the
senator from Arizona most beautiful
state I've always admired Barry
Goldwater and I have to say that I am a
die-hard Democrat but mine because he
did stand up for what he believed in I
think really something that people are
sick and tired of this this going on
tonight has been going on for the last
two weeks
I wonder what's going on that we should
know about this being hidden because of
the cover that's going up on this
particular situation I thank the economy
of this country and foreign trade is one
of the biggest problems we have in
America today and I don't think it has
been addressed by the news media as it
should have been fare tree
I think fair trade is something should
be addressed I don't think it has been
by this administration a lot of talks
been about it but nothing has been done
in regards to it sir I've been losing
jobs as a thousand a day and American
people are more concerned about sir we
we only have a few seconds I'd like for
him to at least answer that question for
you I'm sorry I had to cut you off thank
you sir and thank you for your statement
about Senator Barry Goldwater I agree
it's time we put the Iranian thing
behind us make sure that doesn't happen
again and get about this issue of the
trade deficit because the trade deficit
deficit is indeed as you say costing
thousands of jobs what I'd like to
remind you that the trade deficit is
directly connected to
the delvar all deficit problem that is a
issue that the Congress the United
States should address and we can address
it if we show the political courage to
make the spending reductions across the
board including defense that are
necessary so we stop mortgaging our
children's futures and we reduce this
terrible trade deficit which is a drain
on our economy thank you thank you
share his view of that c-span it's a lot
of fun thank you sir
I'd like to thank you senator elect John
McCain and hope you have a wonderful 6
years in the Senate and I'd like to
thank our viewers for calling in good
night